histoire fascinante, qui s'est
écrite en partie au Québec
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
Approchez! Approchez!
La Cité d'archéologie et
d'histoire de Montréal, Pointe-
à-Callière, vous invite à entrer
sous le chapiteau et à découvrir
l'histoire fasinante des arts
du Cirque.
ÉLISABETH CÔTÉ, chargée projets,
Expositions, Pointe-à-Callière
- C'est une histoire qui a
à peu près 250 ans. On est en
1768 en Angleterre. Il y a
Philip Astley qui développe
un premier cirque en dur où
il invite des écuyers à faire
des acrobaties et ça suscite
l'attrait des foules
dès cette période.
Au québec, 1797 : un premier
cirque permanent à Montréal,
avec le John Bill Rickets, qui
vient s'installer dans le vieux
Montréal tout près de
Pointe-à- Callière.
- L'exposition "Place au
Cirque" présente 350 objets
variés qui témoignent de
l'évolution du cirque d'hier à
aujourd'hui et de sa place
dans l'imaginaire collectif.
ANNE ÉLISABETH THIBAULT, dg
Pointe-à-Callière
- Vous imaginez, la ménagerie,
les éléphants, les girafes
qui arrivent dans les chars
àllégoriques, colorés avec
des personnages absoluments
fabuleux, ça attrirait beaucoup
la curiosité et ça a aussi
allumé la flamme chez certains
jeunes québécois.
- Effectivement, rapidement,
des troupes québécoises se
lancent dans l'aventure.
- On va alors voir
le développement de différentes
familles qui vont créer
des cirques, qui vont
se déplacer soit aux États-Unis
ou au Canada, dont le premier
est Louis Cyr; donc, soit
le premier entrepreneur à avoir
sa propre troupe.
- Le parcours thématique et
chronologique, nous permet de
découvrir les avancées qui ont
menées au types de cirque que
l'on connait aujourd'hui.
L'expoistion se termine par
un hommage à 7 troupes
québécoises contemporaines,
qui partagent un langage commun,
mais qui ont des esthétiques
bien différentes. De quoi
changer notre vision du monde
circassien.
PASCAL JACOB, dir. artistique
Festival Mondial Cirque Demain
- C'est de prendre conscience
que le cirque est universel
et qu'il a généré des oeuvres
littéralement, qu'il a généré
des témoignages plastiques,
graphiques, esthétiques, et
qu'on est bien loin simplement
d'un spectacle pour se divertir;
c'est ça aussi. Mais je pense
que le cirque recèle une part
de notre mémoire collective
en tant qu'humanité.
- "Place au cirque",
une exposition qui fera pousser
des hourras aux petits
et aux grands qui ont gard